good evening members officers
and member of the press welcome to the
cabinet meeting
just
oh sorry a member of the public
oh sorry couldn't see you there oh good
evening
welcome
um and um just a bit of housekeeping so
the if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices by the stairs
please do not use the lifts assembly in
holy Square on the green officers will
assist you and advise when it's deemed
safe to return to the chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
Charles
the following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
item 5 counselors Keen
item six councilor Garner item seven
councilor Whitehead does anyone else
wish to speak councilor Everett item six
please
councilor wing
Council Austin
careful what you promise
[Laughter]
five six and seven
Translate
and cancer yikes
oh that's good because there was no one
to speak under that so
I've got a full house
okay so I've got to update my next sheet
so we will move on to apologies I have
received apologies from counselor Pugh
but everyone else is present Charles
item two is decorations of interest does
anyone have any interest to declare in
the items of business on the agenda this
evening
no Charles
items three is minutes of the previous
meeting to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 12th of
January 2023
the copy was attached to the agenda pack
I propose that we approve the minutes do
I have a secondary
councilor Bob bayford do members agree
item four is the 2023 stroke 24 budget
and
2023-27 medium-term financial plan to
introduce councilor David Saunders
thank you leader the report before us
this evening is largely as we reported
at the cabinet meeting on the 12th of
January for the budget
2023-24 and the MTF s for 2023
2027. the key points as was mentioned at
our previous meeting
were that we are recommending
um
net spending on local Services by 3.5
million or 19.6 percent for the budget
year this is a really significant
increase and the district council faces
the same cost increases as everyone else
on fuel transport and pay and this has
to be funded
inflation is a 40-year high as we all
realize and appreciate and the current
economic climate makes it difficult to
predict to the Future
I'm therefore pleased to say that we
have prepared a balanced budget and this
ballot budget was considered by the
overview and scrutiny panel on the 17th
of February and out of that overview and
scrutiny panel was one recommendation
which is detailed in section two of the
report before you this evening I won't
go through the detail no doubt councilor
Yates is going to elaborate and
having read the recommendation from
overview in scrutiny I am
looking to
propose option free
which is cabinet defers any decision
about the cold Buster service until an
assessment
of the broad options for the use of the
better care fund is considered within a
separate report to a subsequent cabinet
meeting I have to say that the reason
I've come to this decision in proposing
option three is that during the
style chamber meetings that we had and
for the record we had 90 meetings and we
looked at 19 presentations from heads of
service this is something that didn't
come up in any of those discussions and
as members will know within the budget
we have allowed for additional resource
within the budget for certain areas and
I appreciate what council Yates has said
with regards to this being if you like
cost neutral in respect to the budget
but I'd like to see a report just to
find lives and make sure that this is
the right way to go so I'm proposing
that we recommend or we approve option
three within the report this evening
chairman leader sorry thank you
thank you councilor Saunders
um to speak under 20.1 councilor Yates
thank you leader
so I do understand the issue of trying
to
have an officer report analyzing all the
details that could be used
um for the better care fund
um our position remains that people are
going cold now there is a cost living
crisis now the money can be spent now
um
I've got well Helen and I share with a
um Ward and we've got residents coming
to us unable to pay their electricity
bills going colds
um
and energy bills are for 400 pounds a
month for some residents so
I think this was an opportunity that can
still be taken up so my question
um to councilor Saunders
um is if this option
is on the table in this report
provided provided within the report will
they consider it
when the officers
bring it forwards obviously we're going
to push to have this in as our position
but
would would cancel someone just consider
this if it is brought forward by
officers again in a few months time
thanks
councilor Saunders
absolutely
um
you're absolutely right and I wish this
was raised shall we say pre-Christmas
Because by the time we get a report and
they get things get moving
um if the weather forecast is correct we
may well be into a much warmer but I
think preparations are correct and I
think preparations right and proper and
um
I do see this is the way forward
particularly with people who are living
in older housing stock where perhaps the
insulation when they were built and
refurbished wasn't up to speed so
absolutely something that we will
consider
wonders so cancer Saunders has moved
um that's the option three is um
recommended the recommendation is
adopted by option three
um do I have a secondar councilor Jill
bayford do members agree
thank you we move now to item five
public spaces protection order FANUC
District Council number five atherstone
and ethelbert road to introduce
councilor cup
thank you leader standard District
Council is committed to improving the
environment and improving Community
safety directly relating to this is our
commitment
sorry is the commitment
to this is commitment is the council's
ability to address anti-social behavior
and related complaints a remedy to
reducing the impact of behaviors
affecting communities is the
implementation of a public space
protection order a pspo a pspo is a is
an order made by local Authority if it
is satisfied on reasonable grounds that
two conditions are met and these are
number one that activities being carried
out within a public place have a
detrimental effect on the quality of
life of those in the locality or it is
likely they will
that number two that's the effect or
likely effect of these activities is or
is likely to be of a persistent or
continuing nature such as to make the
activities unreasonable the proposed
pspo area covering atherstone and
ethelbert Roads including 195 meter
Alleyway between the two has been
responsible for seven percent of all fly
tips in thanet from December 2020 to
December 2021 and 32 percent of all fpns
issued in thanet were related to
offenses on atherstone Road
the pspo seeks to ensure that households
landlords and agents take equal
responsibility for the placement of
waste to reduce anti-social noise and to
close off the alleyway between the two
rows with Gates
whilst undertaking consultation on the
proposal of the 80 people from the
community who responded 92 percent
agreed or strongly agreed with proposals
for the pspo it is proposed that this
order gives discretion and flexibility
to officers to exercise enforcement of
these Provisions where it is believed to
be having a detrimental effect
the pspo
will be in place for a maximum of three
years as per the law but will be
reviewed to ensure it is effective in
its approach in tackling the issues that
affect business and the public
I would like to recommend that cabinet
exercises its powers under the
anti-social Behavior crime and policing
Act of 2014 to introduce his public
spaces protection order covering
athelstone and effort roads and the
alleyway between the two roads in
cliftonville West and approves
recommendations one and two for the
implementation of this order thank you
Nita
thank you councilor to speak under 20.1
I have councilor Keem
thank you leader a pspo for athelstone
and apple Bert roads is good news the
labor group fully support this these
roads have have been a fly-tipping hot
spot and a problem which previous
efforts have not been able to resolve
welcome as it is I do have some concerns
to make this successful there needs to
be strong and visible enforcement with
working CCTV able to capture
identifiable images
in the risk Matrix the ability of
tenants to maintain the area is
identified as a possibly preventing
tenants being able to maintain it in the
long term
whereas it certainly there has been an
economic upturn in property prices
and there are some beautiful
well-maintained houses on both roads
there are still a number of residents in
low Quality Private rented properties
who have not enjoyed this upturn unless
you need in consideration going forward
the risk assessment also highlighted the
highly transient population
and says work has been undertaken to
reduce transience
what form has this work taken and what
figures support this because being
regularly in athelstone Road I know
there are still a huge enemy and I know
it's a particularly in the north to four
population but there's certainly a large
population of school-aged children often
playing in the roads
and finally the report highlights the
Broken Window Theory whereby an area
invisible disrepair is seen as not cared
for and more likely to encourage more of
the same behavior so I would like to see
greater encouragement for residents by
positive reinforcement and enhancement
of the area and positive publicity to
start chipping away at the current
negative perception of these roads thank
you
thank you councilor King councilor Cole
will respond
uh thank you and thank you councilor
King Athletics once and I'm pleased that
you do support this because I think that
um this is is very important because uh
as a council we've got to be seen to be
doing the right thing and I think this
is absolutely the right thing to do in
this area
um with regards to CCTV there will be uh
four CCTV uh looking over the alleyway
especially
um and that will be able to make sure
that we're covering make sure that this
PCSB
I don't know what I'm never gonna get
this right pspo there we go uh is is
being carried out properly
um and is I don't know if Eden did you
want to comment at all on
the what was your second question again
sorry about
the Ford
um you know sort of maintaining the area
and hoping that we'd look at positive
enhancement enhancements for it but also
the issue of the transience of the
population
um and what what work has been done to
address the transience because as I say
sort of there's lots of of
multi-occupancy private rented
properties in the road
um and I haven't noticed there's not
been the same transients
thank you for clarifying my apologies
um with regards to making sure that we
showing that the efforts of everyone in
that area I think it is really important
and
um I'm sure that our social media team
will be Keen to that when it is looking
good in in a good condition that we will
be publicizing that and showing that
actually the the good effects that the
pspo is is having on the area
and in terms of the the second question
that you raised I will refer to Penny or
even on that on the
um thank you for your question counselor
in terms of the transience of the
population
um the thanet multi-agency task force
had been working in that area for a
little over two years now one of the big
pieces of work that we've undertaken is
joint work with an organization called
save the children and in developing the
at the work around athelstone and Ethel
but Road one of the things that we
reflected upon when it comes to the
transience of the population is the
early life experience he's a very young
children particularly those aged zero to
four and the fact that having insecure
housing can have a lifelong impact on
them so working very closely we've saved
the children what we did was we
outreached to all of the families in
that geographical area aged zero to four
and try to encourage them to stay at
that location by by putting them in
touch and signposting with organizations
that provide services for children and
by also doing additional work with the
district council going into properties
to make sure that those properties were
fit a purpose I don't have the specific
figures around the population transients
but I'm sure with colleagues I can make
those available for you the work that
we've undertaken on applestone road is
still ongoing obviously the second part
that I want you to cover
um in your second question which is
actually a good one around those who may
not be in a position to support some of
the activities obviously the enforcement
teams are any of the agencies that can
provide enforcement in and around a PSP
or are sensitive to the needs of the
local community I am pleased to say one
of the things that we developed was um
we managed to achieve some grant funding
from defra for the development of the
alleyway between the two roads to make
it a genuine community resource and
we've allocated some 12 800 pounds to
the applestone Road Tenants and
residents Association and they're about
to go out to consultation with both
streets and the residence continuing
about the best use of that area the
intention needs to make it into a
clearly defined community space
specifically for that community
point one cancer Austin
thank you leader um I'd like to Echo
what council King said the green group
is Thoroughly supportive of this there's
there's been a need for a long time for
some from distinct action in this area
of of Clintonville and we would like to
pay tribute to
um to cabinet members councilors and
Eden and his team and most particularly
to the Atherton Road Tenants and
residents Association and residents
who've got behind this and I'm really
encouraged to hear from Eden the balance
between enforcement on the one hand
which is going to be essential but
support for vulnerable residents on the
other because it's going to be a
delicate
thing to achieve
and I'm particularly encouraged by the
plans for the alleyway and the question
I wanted to ask was we have a number of
Alleyways of this kind perhaps not as
badly fly tipped but fly tipping in
Alleyways is a real big issue all across
thanet we know of other authorities
where the gating of Alleyways has had
really beneficial effects and brought
the community together certainly in my
own Ward and in other words in Ramsgate
we have Alleyways that are a real
problem and we have Community gardening
groups and residence groups that would
really like to get their hands on them
but a lot of the time they don't know
who the alleyway belongs to
and that has been a sticking point and
my understanding I may have got this
completely wrong but I remember a
conversation a long while ago with Mr
Porter trying to identify who was
responsible for a particular
um path up to a a row of houses was it
us or was it KCC that Mr Porter
mentioned access to software that I
believe officers may have
um that the rest of us could really
benefit from having access to if it's
possible because then we could be
working with some of those Community
groups and working out which of these
things are ours which are of of no known
provenance which of them belonged to KCC
and we could actually develop some
positive environmental plans along those
lines in a number of areas of thanet and
in doing so cut fly tipping
substantially thank you
thank you Council Austin
um he's somewhat strayed from the item
the agenda item but um I'm sure
councilor cup has noted this and uh
probably we need to go away and prepare
a report outside of this because it has
strayed from the agenda item but I
appreciate that your initial comments
regarding the positivity of the alleyway
but I will hand you to councilor Cup who
will no doubt uh
how he wishes to take that particular
point forward
thank you leader um and thank you
Council Austin for your comments I'm
pleased that you welcome this as well
um as I said it's it's good news for the
area and
um you're absolutely right there is
always uh an issue with with Alleyways
and certain plots of land as to who owns
that and who the responsibility is to
clear it up and cut the grass and
whatever that may be
um and I'm very happy to to look in to
see if we can get a report around what
KCC is using and if that's something
that we can use here as well excellent
thank you
maybe it's something we can bring in for
the uh
Charles III coronation I think he has a
day of community engagement so maybe we
can have an Alleyway coronation Alleyway
sort out so uh I can
yes I don't want to go too much I don't
want to go much further up this Alleyway
but uh I think um it would be something
that maybe we could suggest that we that
we wrap up with the coronation
celebration so just just a suggestion
proves that I read the dictate that came
out yesterday so um
um so
um I believe that you have moved um
option recommendations one and two do I
have a secondary councilor Bob bayford
do members agree
item six notice of motion regarding
water supply and treatment to introduce
is myself
so without further ado
the quality of bathing Waters around
than it is a critical part of the
district's appeal to visitors and
tourists and an essential part of our
local visitor economy
there are 13 designated bathing Waters
in stannett and data about water quality
was last published in November 2022 the
results were published against raised
standards for two bacteria types and
showed that than it has eight beaches
rated as excellent
the notice of motion presented to
council was fundamentally flawed in that
the evidence demonstrates that over the
last few years bathing water quality has
been improving
that said there are still instances of
sewage release mainly as a result of an
aging network of combined sewers
combined with periods of heavy rain
during these incidents approximately 90
of the content is rain water and surface
water runoff
there is always room for further
Improvement as we keep reminding
Southern water therefore although
recommending to cabinet that we reject
the motion that I am recommending to
cabinet that we reject the notice of
motion we will continue to work with our
statutory Partners to drive Improvement
for example we are already working with
Southern water and KCC to improve
drainage within the district
the project at George Park in Westbrook
is a successful example of this and
further projects are planned including
Dane Park in Margate to remove surface
water from the network
surface water is fundamentally the the
underlying problem that that has this
knock-on effect with the
the events of uh that we have
experienced over the last year or so
I move the recommendence set out in the
report
to speak under 20.1 councilor Garner
thank you leader
we are we are all overly familiar with
the numerous issues we've had to put up
with due to the inadequacies of Southern
Waters infrastructure over the last few
years those failures have led to
frequent releases of sewage into the sea
around our Coastline and the motion
raised by councilor Smith was our
suggestion on how we as a council could
do more to make sure the coastline and
the resident services are safeguarded
when planning decisions about future
health in developments are made
a number of other councils across the
country have considered unadopted some
of these measures to help protect their
residents and I do have to say I was a
bit disappointed that the
administration's group voted against
allowing councilors to debate the matter
knowing the strength of feeling about
the current situation with Southern
water in the community it was a shame
you didn't want to hear from some of us
before the matter was referred to
cabinet
since that meeting last October
not only have there been more sewage
releases around the coastline but we've
also had a significant increase in the
number of water outages to Residents
homes and to businesses
the major outage last December was
caused by a burst water main
and the three outages this year
according to Southern Waters Kent
stakeholder manager
have been due to power failures tripping
booster pumps at the vanfield water
booster station made worse by failures
of backup generators each of these
faders highlights an infrastructure that
is currently not fit for purpose neither
to maintain a reliable service for its
current workload but especially not for
the major housing developments planned
over the next few years
while I welcome the fact that it is
recommended that officers will write to
the environment agency
requesting a position statement and I
also understand that southern water
officials are to be invited to answer
questions at the March overview and
scrutiny meeting
We Believe an awful lot more needs to be
done
I believe that especially in light of
recent events the conclusions in this
paper need to be entirely Revisited
as a council we cannot continue to give
permission for more and more large
housing developments without the
required infrastructure upgrades being
completed first to ensure that the
infrastructure is fit for purpose
we would ask that the cabinet consider
withdrawing this paper and come back
urgently with a proposal as to how we
can do this before it is too late
thank you
thank you Council Garner um
we carefully considered all of the all
of the points there and as I make notice
a point in uh my response is that some
of the arguments are fundamentally
flawed which makes it difficult to pass
the motion
um uh in its entirety of
um we have
um
obviously
responded and noted that certain
elements that we can take up in fact I
can inform you that I have written again
to the chief executive and asked him to
come to uh full Council to explain the
actions I haven't yet received a
response I don't appear to have built
the same sort of relationship that that
I had with Ian McAuley but I would
imagine that he's probably a little bit
nervous to come into the lines then but
um uh Toby Welling Wellington is
more than active within uh
within our Communications but uh
um there are other point to raise as
well is that I sit on the Pathfinder's
task force and represent than it on that
so there there has been some positive
moves forward
um since um the infamous uh event that
took place a week after I first became
leader of the council but um we're
certainly on their radar as far as the
south east is concerned we are high
priority on on the Pathfinders and
solutions that are going on but it
Remains the fact that new housing isn't
the issue here the issue is old housing
stock that doesn't have the the water
separation and that is fundamentally our
problem so a lot of investment needs to
go into that to to eliminate the spills
but at the same time the failure in the
infrastructure and it is around one
particular site I understand but I
received notification today that um The
Works that took place overnight is
completely it has actually
secured some robust backup
so the initial failure was a burst pipe
which was in a hugely difficult place to
access
um so that was the delay there in
actually getting it repaired
um which was a result of the freezing
and change of temperature conditions I'm
not making excuses to tell them what I'm
just explaining about how how their
responses come through
um two occasions there was a power
supply which is inexcusable
um this was one of the reasons why the
fullness Point failed
um
that that's a bad spill that we had
there
um and I understand now there's all
sorts of measures in place for for that
never to happen again and thank goodness
it hasn't
um and the last point was
um I believe uh pump failed
which again I think is an inexcusable
part if you have a if you've got a
massive infrastructure like that you
should have backup at least back up
one backup standby and then you should
have one that back up backs up the
backup because it's fundamentally I
think uh
I'm not sure of the actual numbers but a
substantial part of broadstairs loss
their water supply so I have I have been
making lots of noise on this but we do
have separate issues here one is an
infrastructure problem but our main
problem in planet is our separation
which is what the Pathfinder is all
about and I can assure you that you know
having a presence on that task force
does make quite a lot of difference but
I know that our Engineers have been
dealing very closely with this but I I
think southern Walters still have a long
way to go for their resilience
so
um the next speaker is counselor Everett
thank you later I wonder if we might
have been better off if the motion had
just read this Council believes that
southern water is not fit for purpose
you know I think we might have been able
to debate that but I don't think there'd
have been much dissent because I think
it's pretty much the universal view
across the council that this
organization is useless and is not
serving our population in an appropriate
way
unfortunately as the local Authority
we're not really in a position to get
rid of it
um so to some extent I I wish that the
roding group had allowed this motion to
be debated
um but I also accept that it is a deeply
flawed motion I think it's far too long
for a start and perhaps as a council we
ought to have a discussion about how
long motions ought to be because this is
more of an essay than a motion but it
does Express the extreme concern that
certainly many residents and I know the
council have about southern water and
it's
current operation I'm pleased that the
issues which have most recently come up
in broadstairs have been referred to
scrutiny I think by my colleague
councilor Keane and I look forward to
the discussion that's going to take
place at scrutiny about those
I think that the report is useful
because it debunks or at least
challenges some of the points which are
made in the motion
um one thing I did want to highlight is
where it says loopholes in National
planning rules mean we Face steep rises
in new Housing Development
well I have to say they're not loopholes
that's policy the policy of the
government has been presumption in favor
of development and its government policy
which is why we have lots of sites
allocated for housing in our area
um but we have to recognize that whilst
we might have different views about what
type of housing should be built and how
it should be built there is significant
housing need we have a substantial
waiting list for affordable rent in this
district and this council is trying to
address that and will continue to try
and address it but we have to recognize
we have to balance all our concerns and
I don't believe that providing more
affordable rent properties is a lower
concern
than the issue in dealing with the
sewage because as has been pointed out a
lot of the service problem is related to
existing development and the existing
infrastructure it's not the case that
adding to it incrementally adds
incremental to the load and the problem
and in any case new development has to
go through quite a complex process in
terms of the local plan and we may or
may not think that that's appropriate
but or is adequate but there is a
process around it to determine what
infrastructure is available to service
that development
the other thing I wanted to highlight
really relates to proposal eight which
talks about the southern water response
in planning consultations
um
the fact is that as I understand it
Southern water a statutory consultation
console T and the council takes its
advice on the situation relating to
water and sewage from Southern water and
their advice would be a material
consideration in planning consents
so it's quite a strange situation really
because at least I think we have a fair
amount of confidence in most of our
statutory Coastal teas Kent County
Council for example on highways I
wouldn't think the council has a huge
amount of confidence in what southern
water tells us but when I hear proposals
for development to be stalled or blocked
because of the inadequate sewage I have
to say that the council is is legally
obliged to listen to the opinion and
take him take into account the views of
Southern water it can't substitute its
own opinions and I don't think it would
ever be lawful for this Council to block
all development
um in while it waited for
um infrastructure improvements I think
that their planning Powers will simply
be taken away from us if we try to do
that and we would not be taken seriously
so I hope nobody's going to pursue that
particular line of argument thank you
uh thank you Council Everett no um I
think
the stud Marsh nitrate
stalling is um
evidence of that you can actually crash
the economy of the local economy
um as well for its development
um
by having a complete blanket ban on all
new builds
um as we said earlier it isn't the new
builds that is the problem and having
visited the poor Hall Lane site which
provides total affordable housing and
affordable rents which I was delighted
to see and that demonstrates all the
points that you were making that they
are very stringent controls on not only
the insulation which is another big
subject that we talk about the heating
but also the water and the whole sewage
uh system itself that feeds into it so I
I agree the worst thing that this this
gov this council is council could do is
is to actually look at this as a reason
to stop all building it is building the
right type of
um property and and I gain support I
mean we're getting straying away from
the water subject but I totally agree we
have to build more affordable housing
and affordable rental housing in this
District so that's where it flies in the
face with me about with Southern water I
think our issues have got to be to try
and get Southern water to invest further
into the infrastructure and to work with
them to on on sub programs like we like
we have in this Pathfinders so
um I I thank you for that reasoning
behind why that uh itemate isn't um
feasible and probably something that we
actually don't want to do
um and and I agree with you if the
motion had been
do we want to pass a vote of no
confidence in southern water I think I
might have been inclined to support that
and I think the whole chamber probably
would but um it because it was so
fragmented and there were elements we
couldn't adopt the whole motion so I
agree it would uh we should if it had
been focused down
um a little bit more refined then maybe
we could have actually agreed to uh to
pass the motion through so
um next to speak and uh 20.1 is
councilor wing
thank you thank you leader uh I sort of
disagree because new homes have people
that live in them and people that live
in new homes actually use water and
create waste water so I don't know how
we can say that new buildings won't
increase pressure on the system but I
think we all I mean I'm not going to
blame anybody or any political party
because I think we sh we we have a a
common horror of watching waste go into
our waterways in the coast so we have a
shared a stance on the situation
I was disappointed that we weren't able
to debate the motion but it's given me
some time to actually do some research
myself so I am going to read
background as we know Southern water
provides fresh water and treats
Wastewater for all the households and
businesses in thanet at the following
treatment sites one of which is shared
with other another area of Kent which I
didn't realize until the last few days
mince to Waste Water treatment work
Services Minster Monkton St Nicholas at
Wade 4 300 people weatherless Hill a
Services Ramsgate sandwich and deal 99
000 people weatherless Hill B Margate
and broadstairs 93 000 people which is
why at the last Southern water we didn't
have the Ramsgate end of Southern Waters
issues which I found quite concerning
and why in the information I've got back
from Southern water about the where the
outflow pipes are they've only given me
information from Margate upwards but we
we have a southern part of thanet which
does include ramsgay and Ramsgate
service we share with sandwich and Deals
so there's a service there which is
further impacted that's a total of nine
196 6 300 people of which 140 000
roughly authenic residents
these systems are clearly not coping
particularly in periods of of heavy rain
when both weatherly's Hill systems are
often overwhelmed resulting in sewage
discharges into the sea from Associated
outflow pipes indeed we are all very
much more informed of the reasons why
and some of the measures being taken by
Southern water to tackle the problem
much of which are important measures but
are viewed by many and the green party
as sticking plasters these measures do
simply do not address the twin problem
of poor and inadequate infrastructure
and excessive local plan housing numbers
that are not based in in the evidence of
actual need for thanet
Southern water's own document water use
and cost indicates that an average
household of 2.4 people would use
240 cubic meters of fresh water and
create 222 cubic liters of Wastewater to
be treated annually in August 2021 TDC
commissioned a local housing need
assessments report this gave Baseline
data housing numbers of 66
156 in 2020
by 2031 eight years from now an
additional 17
140 new homes will be built representing
a 25.9 increase in our housing numbers
and creating as a result because people
live in these houses and Associated you
would assume 25.9 increase in need for
fresh water that's 11
270 cubic meters of water daily and
Wastewater to be treated at 10
440.8 cubic meters daily by 2040 if not
challenged there is a real possibility
that new housing numbers will increase
by a further
4521
640 representing a staggering
32.7 increase again you would assume
with an Associated 32.7 increase in the
need for fresh water and and Wastewater
to be treated
uh these figures I found quite shocking
actually I'm getting to the point please
are we certain
I will do I'm coming to the motion are
we certain the present system can cope
or will we see a system that is
overwhelmed daily interestingly the same
report States the national population
data increase fourth and it is lower
than than Kent the southeast and
National rates at 13 percent
so why are we why have we got our
present numbers
consequently I believe uh we need to
it's further our situation is further
impacted by three three things an old
outdated and quite frankly passed it
sell by date fresh water and wastewater
infrastructure which we all agree on
uh
the fact we are the most water stressed
area in the UK acknowledged by Ian
McClary in the 21st of April meeting an
excessive new housing numbers which
clearly have no basis in actual evidence
I therefore urge us TDC because we have
shared concerns this is this isn't the
greens think more about it or labor
thinks more about it we have shared
concerns and our residents have many
concerns we need a better understanding
of the daily capacity of Southern Waters
infrastructure to deliver fresh water
and tree Wastewater and we need that
data in relation to the new housing
that's coming on board and the people
that will live in there
we need uh we need and this is the bit
of the motion that I think we do need
and I sit on planning we need Southern
water to provide additional modeling
information for new housing developments
and the potential impact they will have
on our water infrastructure system we
need that for all planning applications
I've often asked about southern Waters
uh information at planning and it
usually it comes back there's no concern
what I'd also like us to do is to
immediately petition our MP and Mr Gove
following his recent statement which
said
housing figures should be a starting
point and he's going to give local
councils more flexibility coming on to a
completely different subject now it's
related leader because we it's not
related the battles of our housing
number is not related to the lack of
infrastructure uh resilience within
Southern we we have a water yes we have
a water infrastructure infrastructure
system which is not presently fit for
purpose and we're going to add
additional stresses to it so those are
the three things I believe we should be
doing as a as a as a as a council thank
you well I again
um well
state that I have written to the chief
executive to come and talk to members so
that can be covered from that area as
far as the housing numbers go concerned
I don't need any reminding that we need
we have been told that we need another 4
000 units but that is for the plan that
is to fill the gap between 19 20 31 and
2040. so um
the whole point about the uh that you
make about that we haven't got enough
fresh water and daily we have we have
problems we don't have problems daily
um we do not have a shortage of fresh
water that is not the issue and I I
appreciate that you've done a lot of
work working out who shares what sewage
systems and processing
um sewage plants in thanet and where we
share it with neighbor Neighbors but we
also share
other infrastructure service needs in
that we share the National Grid so it's
not really something that you can
compare like for like
um the whole point is is that they need
to sort out and I will repeat this again
we need to sort out the surface water
drainage away from our sewage because
there is more than adequate
capacity within the processing within
the sewage processing to take care of
the whole of we're only actually
utilizing something like 20 30 percent
of the sewage capacity at the processing
sewage plants it is the drainage the
surface water drainage that is causing
the problem if we can eliminate that
away from the sewage we have absolutely
tons of capacity that is that is the
challenge
and unfortunately this Council many
years back and I I can't remember the
year and I'm not gonna I don't even know
what administration so this isn't a
political statement there was an
application by Southern water to build
um storage tanks storm water storage
tanks and a certain part of the district
which was absolutely thrown out of this
Council so in some cases it's you know
you need to think a bit long term
strategically and hopefully
we can actually get Southern water to to
give us priority which I think they're
actually doing in it but it's up to
members to speak to uh
to speak to the chief executive when
when he arrives here
um and I you know and the subject of
housing that is a completely different
subject and I agree maybe southern water
should some send someone along to
planning perhaps that would be a good
idea like Kent County Council should
probably send someone along from
highways which they don't do so uh you
know um
it is I don't know what their tick box
criteria is to it and I don't know
whether it is a full-blown investigation
that they pass and they overlay on the
plans that come in but I mean we'd have
to have a conversation with you know the
the Bob Porter maybe to see what
involvement they have and and how and
what checks and balances they do with
the the supply but I think it's a bit
unfair to say that we have daily issues
with our fresh water supply because I
can't agree with that I don't think we
do
um so I didn't say that I my my point
was are we certain the present situ this
present system can cope so I was posing
a question not stating
not stating something at that point well
I I'm not an expert in water supply so I
I can't State whether or not it is that
is definitely a question for when the
chief executive enters in but
um all your points have been taken on
and I admire you for your for your
research within it and um I think we're
all
are far far further up the learning
curve on sewage treatment works and
Water Supplies than than what I ever
thought I would be but um it is it is
true South Southeast England has
is a dry spot of
the country but I think Ian McAuley in
the same time he was stating that he
lived in some very Arizona or somewhere
like that where they actually don't have
anything like the problems that we have
even though it never rains there so um
it's it's an ongoing thing but I would
urge members to once we get the uh
their Senior Management here then you
know they are the people to to attack on
this um I constantly write to Michael
Gove about housing numbers etc etc in
fact I probably am on the naughty step
with the LGA today because I told them
exactly the same thing so um you know we
are all on the same page really
um it's just the case of how to tackle
it and
I hope that
satisfies you some way that we actually
can do something about it
um
speak under 20.1 Council Austin
thank you leader I think I bring a
the apologies of council Smith that
she's not here because she's with a sick
family member this evening
um and her apologies I think for the
essay that has been so uh so roundly
criticized um that that uh that was her
attempt at getting a a notice of motion
um I think the main thrust of what she
was trying to ask was can we routinely
ask Southern water the environment
agency and possibly other bodies as well
for a bit more information for our
planning committee when we're looking at
large developments that appears to me
not to be complex and not to be anything
other than common sense
it also strikes me that actually without
doing that by turning down the
opportunity of doing that and as
counselor Garners pointed out this is
something that many other councils have
already adopted including conservative
lead councils I'm concerned that we may
be not doing what we're supposed to be
doing under the national planning policy
framework which is talking about
preventing new and existing development
from contributing to being put it on
acceptable risk from or being adversely
affected by unacceptable levels of soil
air water or noise pollution development
should where possible help to improve
local environmental conditions such as
air and water quality surely if we were
routinely to ask for additional
information they don't have to provide
it but if we routinely asked for it and
we could establish as you have said
leader a better relationship with
Southern water so that they feel
confident to be honest with us where
there might be a problem I accept
absolute what you're saying that the
existing problems that we have are as a
result of our older housing and the
inability to separate out the different
streams but going forward looking at the
number of new developments we have on
Greenfield sites it is a real concern
that this may not this may just be the
straw that breaks the camel's back
so um if if we were to bring this motion
back and it were to say can we routinely
please just get more information from
Southern water the environment agency
and some other partners might that be
something that would be acceptable to
the administration
foreign
rather than bringing a motion back which
will go backwards and forwards and
probably will be into the middle of
purda so it wouldn't have a thing I'm
not sure which members of your group sit
on planning
um but
okay so here's a suggestion when you're
at planning and the next application
comes up and you are not satisfied that
southern water you would ask the
officers at planning to say that you're
not happy with that response therefore
please would the planning department
find the following answers I mean I um
will offer the I will pose this to um
the director of planning but I would
suggest that I'm probably not the right
weapon or the right
um person to to be doing all the battles
because you know members are perfectly
at Liberty to write to whoever or raise
whatever whatever committee and I think
more than bringing motions which tend to
go backwards and forwards a little bit
and get a little bit blurred then maybe
it needs to be specific to the actual
topic which in this case appears to be
planning so
um I don't know whether there's any
mechanism for members of the planning
committee to ask for further details
from Southern water if they are not
satisfied that southern water have done
their due diligence or exercise on the
actual planning application so that
would be my suggestion rather than
long-winded motion processes whereby
you've got to satisfy the cabinet that
you're actually asking a question that
we we think that we need to debate it
won't go you know I can write to whoever
you ask me to but I think you would have
better teeth
best placed at the planning committee
itself so I don't know sorry
um sorry Mr Porter if I've
suggested something that's not not
within the policy framework but perhaps
you could add some meat to that well I'm
not sure I can add very much to that but
clearly in planning process
um we are required to consult with
Southern water
and to take into account their
representations in in making a decision
um it doesn't really extend to asking
them to provide more information our
role is to ask them to comment on the
proposals and if we have a comment from
them that says that they're satisfied
that their Network can accommodate the
proposals
um we're not really qualified to to
challenge that
um and I'm not sure that the planning
legislation is necessarily the right way
to raise the concerns that you're
expressing with Southern more so clearly
if there's an application before the
planning committee that members are not
happy with then you know they're able to
ask questions but the decision can only
be taken on things that are set out in
in planning planning legislation
thank you it's on other councils have
done this so we'll watch them with
interest thank you
thank you Council Austin
um I have
I'll remind members again about the
this item so one is to reject the notice
of motion and two to support the
specific responses to the details of the
notice of motion as set out in section
2.10 2.11 and 2.12 to the cabinet report
so I have moved this cabinet do I have a
secondary councilor David Saunders do
members agree
so moving on to item seven is notice of
motion regarding temporary accommodation
to introduce councilor Jill bayford
thank you leader
the council's duty to provide good
quality temporary accommodation is clear
and managing the costs of this whilst
ensuring the best possible service to
homeless household is essential
for this reason that cabinet has already
supported the conversion of firehouse in
Margate to provide temporary
accommodation for eight households and
to propose a budget including an
additional Capital allocation of 2.2
million pounds which incorporates the
council's
2023-24 allocation of new homes bonus
for a further temporary accommodation
project
we have also invested in expanded
homelessness prevention service and
recommended additional resources for
homelessness for
2023-24 to help respond to the growing
pressures as a result of the cost of
living crisis
and the increasing costs and difficulty
in accessing the private rented sector
preventing homes this is both more cost
effective and ensures a better outcome
for households at risk of losing their
own
we have also reaffirmed our commitment
to continue the council's program of
building new Council homes for rent
investing over 8 million pounds each
year over the coming 10 years
the answer to the pressures of temporary
accommodation is not temporary
Commendation but more permanent
affordable homes
it's for this reason that I recommend
that cabinet rejects the notice of
motion and supports the response the
notion of motion on temporary
Commendation set out in this report
thank you
Council of a hood to speak under 20.1
councilor Whitehead
thank you very much leader and thank you
councilor bayford
on the 13th of October 2022 I raised the
following at Council
as we're all aware there is a spiraling
housing crisis in thanet and levels of
private sector evictions are increasing
especially within low-income households
in light of this Rising evictions and
the impossibility of finding and
maintaining a private rental property on
the current lha allowance our need for
temporary housing to keep families in
the area is continually growing
as a council we acknowledge and
recognize the need for further temporary
housing units now before further
inflation makes the necessary growth of
our in-house provision impossible and I
urge cabinet to bring forward such plans
this wasn't an unsurprising or even
unexpected motion and it was an issue
that I felt we were all United on
the pressures on our housing stock and
the need for further in-house temporary
accommodation was clear to all of us and
I brought the motion because it would
have been a perfect point for us to
discuss the needs of our area and hear
and discuss as a council any potential
future plans
however debate and the motion was
refused
and I'm now in the odd position of
having had what I asked for adopted and
included within the budget with the new
homes bonus used to support it which
coincidentally was another request I
made that was previously refused and
then used
but reading that my nation has been
rejected when in actuality it has been
accepted
I am eternally pragmatic and the most
comfortable in the realm of
results-based politics
and having both requests I made accepted
in practicality if not politically is
absolutely fine with me as it is the
outcome that matters for residents and
therefore for me
but I would like it recognize that this
is a rejection on paper only as
expressed within the introduction to
this item
the action's already taken by cabinets
in preparing the draft 2023 budget
support the intention of the notice of
motion that was presented to Council on
the 13th of October 2022
good ideas are good ideas regardless of
where they come from
and debate and discussion of ideas is a
positive tool
including and encouraging the ideas of
others makes us stronger as a council
not weaker and I hope that we can
continue our work towards recognizing
that
thank you
the Whitehead sorry um councilor bayford
would you like
thank you thank you councilor white for
your comments
um
as you be aware of at our regular
meetings with Mr Porter
um
this is the housing team are doing
everything they can to find new
new temporary accommodation we have
plans we have already identified sites
so I I think the point is that you're
asking us to do something that we're
already doing
I cannot see what purpose this most this
notion motion holds when the work has
already been carried out thank you
thank you next speak under 20.1
councilor Austin
um the only thing I wanted to say on
this was to pick up on the the last
thing in fact that councilor White had
said which was about the value of debate
it seems to me disappointing that we
have two examples here of motions that
have been rejected for discussion and
the value of discussion is surely that
we come to an accommodation that we hear
each other's views that members of the
public can see that we are taking
certain matters seriously and
considering them that is surely our
function I think it's deeply
disappointing within a cabinet system to
have stuff shunted to Cabinet all the
time without the opportunity for the
generality of counselors to discuss and
debate them that's all thank you
foreign
if you want to respond counselor back
uh there's little to say really
um
I think the point particularly with this
motion that that
we are all we'll agree that we need more
temporary accommodation we all agree we
have a housing housing problems
um so I and we I think we will agree
that our housing team are doing
everything they can so I really fail to
see what
um how we would benefit from further
discussion and
thank you both councilor bayford I think
we're all um we are all on the same page
and
um I think we fully understand the needs
of the district and
um the hard work is actually not talking
about it but delivering it and that is
the hard part so and hopefully that's
what
we we have been doing and what the
excellent work of our housing team is
doing and what they will continue to do
um as we are all in agreement
we're all agreeing to disagree I don't
know or disagreeing to agree I'm not
really sure which way around it is so
um we
have
item in front of us so that has been
um
I'm just trying to see where there's
anyone else that wanted to speak under
this one I don't believe there is
so councilor Jill bayford has moved this
uh item do I have a seconder councilor
cup do members agree
so thank you members and officers and
members of the public this has concluded
the business for this evening I declare
the meeting closed at 2002. thank you
Charles